Welcome back.
We're now starting section
eight on page 547.
OK.
And I think we're in the third
test. So problem number one,
if e is a set of even numbers--
even integers,
sorry-- e is a set of even
integers, p is a set of
positive integers, and f is a
set of integers less than 5,
which of the following
integers will be
in all three sets?
So we're looking for something
that meets all the
constraints.
So it has to be even, it has to
be positive, and it has to
be less than 5.
OK, so choice A is 6.
6 is not less than 5.
Choice B is 4.
4 is even, 4 is positive,
4 is less than 5.
So the answer is B.
And the other choices don't
work because, C, 1 is odd.
D, 0 is not positive.
And the last choice,
E, negative 2.
Well, that's not positive
either.
Problem number two.
So our answer was B.
Choice B was 4.
Problem number two.
If 8 plus the square root
of k is equal to 15,
then what does k equal?
Well, subtract 8 from both
sides, and you get square root
of k is equal to 7.
Square both sides,
k is equal to 49.
Next problem.
Problem number three.
Let's see If I can
clear image.
Problem number three.
In a poll, 35 people
were in favor of
building a new library.
So 35, yes, they want it.
14, against it.
14 said no.
And 1 person doesn't know.
1 person just has no opinion.
What fraction of those polled
were in favor of building a
new library.
So the people that were
in favor were 35.
And the fraction of the total
people polled-- so the total
people polled was 35 plus
14 plus 1, right?
And what is this?
That's 50.
So that's equal to 35 over 50.
And 35 over 50, if we divide
the top and bottom
by 7, you get 7/10.
So the answer is A.
7/10 were in favor
of the library.
Problem number four.
We've got a kind of crazy
looking figure here.
You have a line that goes
something like this, and it
goes like that and then it
goes like this and looks
something like that.
Close enough.
And what's going on here?
So they tell us that
this angle is 70.
That's 70.
This is 30.
They say that this is
t and this is u.
You probably can't read
that but you see
it in your own book.
In the figure above, what is
the value of t plus u?
This is the angle game again.
Let's see what angles
we can figure out.
So, this is 70, this is 30.
So this angle right here
plus 70, plus 30 has
to equal 180, right?
This angle plus 70, plus 30.
70 plus 30 is 100.
So this is 80 degrees
right here.
If this is 80 degrees,
this is the
opposite angle to 80 degrees.
So that's going to also
be 80 degrees.
We learned that in
geometry class.
And so if this is 80 degrees--
first of all, what do all of
these angles combined equal? t
plus u, plus 80 are all on the
same triangle.
So they have to add up to 180.
So we know that t plus u has
to be 100 degrees, and
that's choice C.
Next problem.
[? Invert. ?]
OK, problem number five.
Oh, there's a big graph.
According to the graph above,
between which two consecutive
years was the greatest change
in the price of coffee?
Oh, I think I'm going to
have to draw this.
Just so that you see what
I see, hopefully.
OK, and then let me just
write the years.
So this is, it goes
'81 through '86.
So '81, '82, '83,
'84, '85, '86.
Let's see, in 1981-- so let's
see, we have $3.00, $3.75, we
have $4.00, $4.25,
$4.50, $4.75.
In 1981 it cost $3.75.
It's going to take me a little
time to draw this whole thing.
In 1982 it was at $3.50.
Oops, that's $3.50 down
here, not $3.00.
Let me write that,
that's $3.50.
Back to what I was doing.
In 1983 it went to $4.25.
In 1984 it went all
the way to $4.75.
In 1985 it was at $3.75 again.
That looks something
like that.
And then 1986 goes to $4.50.
1986, $4.50.
OK, and what are
they asking us?
According to the graph above,
between which two consecutive
years was the greatest change
in the price of coffee?
Well, let's figure that out.
So here, the change is $0.25.
Here, the change, going from
this year to this year, is--
let's see, $0.25,
$0.50, $0.75.
That's a good contender
right there.
$0.75.
Going from here to here we
only had a $0.50 change.
Then we went from
$4.75 to $3.50.
So this is a pretty big
change, actually.
This looks like our winner.
That's from $4.75 to
actually $3.75, so
this is a $1.00 change.
And then we went from $3.75 to
$4.50, so we had a $0.75
change again.
So the biggest change happened
from 1984 to 1985, choice D.
All that work for a fairly
straightforward problem.
Next problem.
Problem number six.
More drawing for me.
OK.
let's see, more drawing.
Got to be focused,
Sal, focused.
This is negative 1, this
is negative 2, this
is 1, this is 2.
1 and 2.
And what does this
graph look like?
Let's see, we go from here to
here, it looks like, and then
we stay flat here, and then we
go like this, and then we go
flat again.
And what are they asking?
The graph of y equals g of x.
So this is y is equal
to g of x.
Shown above.
If g of k is equal to 1, which
of the following is a possible
value of k?
So g of k is equal to 1.
So when does this
graph equal 1?
Well, this graph equals 1--
add a different color-- it
equals 1 here-- oh,
it equals 1 here.
It equals 1 this entire
period, right?
All of these values are where
g of x is equal to 1.
So what could be the
values of k?
Well, the values of k could
be anywhere between
negative 1 and 0.
All of those could be values
of k, anywhere from here.
Because at all of these values,
g of k is equal to 1.
So let's see.
They have choices.
Minus 1.5 is here.
No, that's over there.
Minus 0.5 is right here.
And g of minus 0.5 is right
here, so that's 1. g of minus
0.5 is equal to 1.
So that looks pretty good.
So that is our answer.
Choice B.
Let's see if I can squeeze
in problem number seven.
I think that would be the most
videos I've ever done-- most
problems in 10 minutes.
If a, b and c are different
positive integers, and 2 to
the a, times 2 to the b, times
2 to the c, is equal to 64,
then they want to know, what is
2 to the a, plus 2 to the
b, plus 2 to the c?
Fascinating.
Well, what do we know about
exponent rules?
2 to the a, times 2 to the b,
times 2 to the c, that's 2 to
the a, plus b, plus c, right?
2 to the what power is 64?
2 to the sixth power, right?
2 to the sixth power is 64.
Actually, I'm going to
run out of time.
So I'm going to do this
in the next video.
I only have 15 seconds left.
See you soon.